Here's the 21st century,
how would Hughes,
John D Rockefeller and Steve Jobs
all rolled into one dynamic package.
His hunger for global change mirrors
the sense of adventure of the great
explorers of the past is ideas considered
crazy by everyone around him have
opens up a new frontiers as he continues
to improve the welds with the aid of
technological advancement.
His goal to make the earth a better place
to live on has expanded to encompass
the entire universe,
including the possibility of supporting
human life on Mars and this episode of
Biographics,
we get up close and personal with the
man who was the model for Marvel's iron
man movie franchise character Tony Stark.
Of course,
the man we're talking about
and must be Elon Musk.
They little mosque was born on June the
28th of 1971 in Pretoria, South Africa.
His Canadian born mother was a dietician
with his father being a mechanical and
electrical engineer.
The boy has a natural leaning towards
technology buying his first computer,
a commodore Vic 20 with money.
He had saved 20 it was just 10 years old.
By the age of 12 he had created
his own video game blaster,
which he sold for $500 as a preteen,
had already taught himself
computer programming.
Musk's life came to a crossroads in
his late teens when he was faced with
compulsory military
service in South Africa.
While he had no problem with the thought
of serving his country in uniform,
he was repulsed by the idea of being
a part of a system that suppressed the
country's indigenous black people.
His desire was to get to
America the land of opportunity,
especially in regards to his growing
fascination with all things related to
computer technology to do so.
However,
he figured he would have to use Canada
as a stepping stone. His mother,
it was still a Canadian citizen and so
steps were taken for Elon to acquire
Canadian citizenship for himself.
Yeah.
After graduating from Pretoria boys high
school and the emigrated to Canada in
June of 1989 age just 17
he had hardly any money,
men's new real connections turning up
on the doorsteps of distant relatives of
his mother and to being
put to work on their farm,
as well as tending vegetables
and shoveling grain. He
got a job at a lumber mill,
cleaning out boilers. Then he managed
to secure a job as an intern, Clark.
It's a local bank. In 1990 he
moved to Kingston, Ontario,
where he began the science degree at
the Queen's University. Two years later,
he was able to achieve his goal
of living in the United States,
transferring his studies to
the University of Pennsylvania.
Within that two more years,
he graduated with double
degrees in science and business.
It was around this time that must came
across a copy of Douglas Adams, his book,
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy.
The book revolves around a supercomputer
which is built to figure out the
ultimate answer to the question of life,
the universe,
and after 7.5 million years of computing,
it spits out the onset,
the number 42 along with that onset,
the computer which can talk,
add some sage advice telling the inquirer.
The problem with you,
to be quite honest with you is that you
never really know what the question is
for mosque reading.
That was a light bulb moment.
He later recalled is highlighters
and important points,
which is that a lot of times the
question is harder than the answer.
Why the time he emerged from university.
MUSC wasn't entirely sure
what the questions were,
but he knew that they were tied up
in three key areas. The Internet,
clean energy,
and the outer space.
In 1995 MUSC enrolled himself in a phd
program for Energy Physics at Stanford
University. Yes. After an
attendance of just two days,
he decided to drop out in order
to launch his first business.
His love for physics.
It never wavered,
but he saw greater opportunities in
the burgeoning internet revolution or
waiting to make society
better and himself rich shot.
Okay.
Mosque realized that as more and more
companies established an online presence,
they would need to have that
printed materials converted
into digital documents.
If he could fill that need,
he would be onto a winner.
Ilan teamed up with his younger brother,
Kimbal team develop content publishing
software design for news and media
companies at a time when
many venture capitalists,
so it never even heard of the Internet.
It's was a major risk.
The products that the mosque brothers came
up with, well, that was called Zip two.
It started life as a tool that would
help people to search for maps and
directions on the Internet with people.
Also being able to post information
through something similar to a micro
blogging system, things that were
tough for mask in these early days.
He had no money,
not even enough to rent an office
and an apartment at the same time.
So in order to combat this,
he rented an office where he slept on
a futon and took care of his personal
hygiene down with the local y
starting with small newspapers.
Moscow was able to quickly grow his client
base agreements were made with large
media companies including the Chicago
Tribune and the New York Times in order to
allow those companies to use zip to,
to make their content readily
available to readers via the Internet.
The program was used by many similar
companies along with ecommerce sites as a
platform for their web presence.
By 1999 visit to corporation
was providing web hosting,
web development and maintenance
services for close to 200 websites.
They came to the attention of the
online city guide citysearch who were
interested in a merger. This
deal, it didn't work out,
but another one did often
just four years of operation.
The Zip to cooperation with sold to
Compaq computers for $307 million in cash
and to further 34
million in stock options.
Okay.
At the age of just 28 Elon Musk,
he was a multimillionaire,
but he was just getting started.
And even before the ink
was dry on the zip to deal,
he had thrown himself into
his next venture and that
was x.com Musk's vision was
to create the world's first online bank
and he invested $10 million to kick it
off.
The goal is to offer every service that
you had gas from a conventional bank,
but with the added benefit that you could
send and receive money securely using
only your email address.
x.com was an immediate success.
After just a year of operation.
It was merged with a money
transfer system called infinity.
The combined businesses were
renamed paypal in 2001 now
working with confederacy
founders,
Peter Thiel and Max Levchin.
The business dropped the idea of a fully
functional online bank and focused on
the feature that seemed to
grab everyone's attention,
the ability to send money to and
from anyone who had the same app.
At this early stage. The system, it
relied on a windows based handheld device.
During the first months of
the merger from January,
1999 through October of 2000 Musk was
CEO of [inaudible] dot com during this
time,
he set up this viral system that grew it
into the world's largest email payment
processor and new customers.
They were offered a $20 cash cards along
with an additional $10 for referring a
friends within two months.
More than a hundred thousand
new customers had come on board,
but not always well within
the company's management.
The problem was Musk's management style,
which can best be
described as dictatorial,
both feel unloved and found it
difficult to work with them.
They were especially frustrated.
It doesn't need to micromanage everything,
just need sands divisions of rose over
which technologies to use and how to
brand and the company.
As a result of such divisions.
Thiel ends Levchin organized
a coup against CEO Musk.
When he was meeting with
prospective customers overseas.
He returns to the country to
discover that he had been fired,
the CEO by the board and replaced
by Peter Teal. Shortly thereafter.
The name of the company was changed
to paypal and this time with a second
capital p.
From that it grew exponentially leading
to a buyout by Ebay in 2002 the cost of
the sale was a staggering
one point $5 billion.
As the largest shareholder,
Musk walked away with a cool $165 million.
Okay.
Even before people were sold,
Musk was onto his next business venture.
Ever since he was a child, he had
been fascinated by space exploration.
He had always been an avid
science fiction reader bands.
Now we had the money to turn
science fiction into reality.
He was convinced that the earth was
destined to collapse as a life sustaining
planet.
The sooner we started working on the
technology required for interplanetary
travel and sustaining life beyond earth,
the better.
In discussions with a friend one day,
Musk complains that despite the vast
improvements in the technology industry,
the space industry has lagged.
Got For behinds.
Since man had set foot on the moon
way back in 1969 it's a peer to him,
but no meaningful progress had been made.
He was determined to change that and
his third company space exploration or
space x was to be his platform to do it.
A major goal of space x is to create
a space vehicle that can take people,
equipment and other necessary resources
to Mars and builds a transportation
infrastructure that will allow humans
to become a multiplanetary species.
When Moscot loves the
world in on his vision,
he was immediately subjected
to ridicule industry experts,
dismissed him as a rich board playboy
claiming that his physics degree in
previous business ventures, I'll be made
him qualified. Do you conceptualize,
develop and build rockets?
However,
they were underestimating mosque
who was not only a quick study,
but who also brought on board the best
engineers from top aerospace companies
such as Boeing,
Twa and NASA Musk.
He was disappointed that NASA seems
disinterested in space exploration.
He wants it to peak the public's interest
in order to encourage NASA to increase
their allocated funds to a project to
land the device on Mars and then build a
bubble by over us.
He also wanted to introduce a cheaper
and safer alternative to space shuttle
travel.
He was struck by the fact that the
Russians were able to produce rockets that
were cheaper and safer than anything
that the Americans could come out with.
He traveled to Russia in an attempt to,
to purchase a refurbished ICBM,
but the deal became too complicated.
MUSC next set his sights on creating
and successfully launching a reusable
rocket, which he called a Falcon one. The
idea was that it could fly off to space,
return to Earth,
and then we launched back to space again.
The first scheduled launch for
Falcon one was in 2005 yeah,
three years later after multiple
failed attempts. How can one,
we're still to have its first successful
flight. Finally, on its fourth attempt,
Falcon one successfully launched
on the back of this success.
Space x was able to secure a one point
$6 billion contract from NASA involving
12 for future flights on their rocket.
Falcon nine to the International Space
Station at Musc is estimated that space x
is efforts can minimize the
u s government's expenses
by around $1 billion every
year.
Yeah.
Musk has always been fascinated by
cars and specifically by the dream of
creating a breed of electric cars that
totally transform the driving experience.
While he was still a
sophomore at university,
he had become aware of the
wells depleting resources.
What was needed was an
alternative source of fuel,
one that would not produce
carbon emissions that were
damaging the environment.
It was from these ideas that Musk
decided to pursue a electric cars or year
after launching space acts.
Musk was introduced to Al Chacone
and Tom Gauge of AC propulsion,
the company behinds and all electric con
known as the t zero Musk was interested
in mass producing the t zero but
you konijn gauge showed no interest.
They did however,
introduce mask to a group of men
who were dedicated to finding a more
environmentally friendly vehicle.
In July of 2003 Musk teamed up with
three of them in rides, mock tarponing,
Gans Martin Eberhard to form
the for Tesla cooperation.
This company was named and recognition
of the father of AC induction motors,
Nikola Tesla. From the very beginning,
Tesla faced an uphill battle.
The contraceptive in electric car was
years away from capturing the public
attention and it's just as
was the case with space x.
The question was loudly asked how a
visionary with no experience in the car
industry could successfully establish a
new company and a new product and stand
against the industry giants.
What's more they were attempting to do
something that those industry giants,
it's simply been unable to do.
In fact, Robert [inaudible],
CEO of General Motors stated that lithium
ion technology for cars was at least
10 years into the future as a result
of the lack of industry enthusiasm.
Very few investors wanted anything
to do with Tesla. In fact,
Moscow to funds the majority of the
operations of the company itself.
The goal of having the furnace road stone
rolling off the assembly line by 2007
never materialized as costs just continued
to mouse just as with x.com years
earlier,
tensions arose among the management's
mosque who was chairman of the board,
has no faith in Martin Eberhard.
The presidents of the company.
Before long they got her heart had been
ousted and MUSC put himself in full
control. He was now the CEO of two
startups and even for a dynamo like Musk,
this was still too much. It's still,
but he had to make both companies work.
His master plan at for Tesla was to build
a luxury electric sportscar along with
eight line of more affordable cars
with electric power and zero emissions.
In 2008 the first
roadster was shipped out.
This $110,000 electric sportscar could
run for 200 miles on a single charge and
was capable of going from zero to 60
miles per hour in less than four seconds.
The more affordable electric car was
called the Tesla model s it's released,
began in June of 2012 sales took off and
there are currently 500 rolling off the
production line every week,
as well as being the CEO of Tesla mosque
is also the chairman of the board of
directors of another
environmental company,
so the city will not the
founder of this company.
He is very involved in
achieving the company's mission
to deliver complete solar
energy systems, do the end users
without any of the upfront fees.
It also promised reduced utility bills
for all of its customers by offering free
installation and zero down
payments to homeowners.
MUSC has made it easier for consumers
to afford solar energy and this
revolutionized the way that
the solar industry has run.
So the city has enjoyed tremendous growth
and success with clients that include
Ebay,
Walmart in the u s military.
This has made it to the number one solar
power service provider in the United
States.
As it being an industry
leader in space travel,
electric cars and solar
power is not enough.
In August of 2013 MUSC proposed a
completely new mode of personal transport.
He called it the hyperloop.
The concept will allow people to travel
between large cities at the speed of
sound allowing passengers to get from
San Francisco to Los Angeles in about 30
minutes.
It involves a vacuum sealed pod that
rides on top of electromagnetic waves very
simply. This is of similar to the way
a surfer's board rides ocean waves.
The partners will glide across the track
at speeds of many hundreds of miles per
hour.
This eliminates the problem,
the friction created by wheels on the
tracks the same month that Musk unveiled
plans for the hyperloop, the crown
sourcing and collaboration platform.
Jumpstart Fund was established comprised
of more than a hundred engineers,
developers, and investors. The creeps up
on the hyperloop as their first project.
In 2014 they formed a
hyperloop transportation
technologies and undertook a
feasibility study.
In 2015 MUSC ran the student competition
to design and build hyperloop pods.
I space x sponsored mile long track
was built in order to run the pods on.
On July the 20th 2017 Musk announced
that he had gained verbal government's
approval to build a hyperloop
track between New York
City and to Washington d c
Elon Musk is one guy who it is
a challenge to keep up with.
In the 12 months from December, 2015
to December, 2016 he still wanted it.
No less than three companies
open AI and not for profit.
Artificial intelligence research
company near Relink Cane,
euro technology startup with the aim of
integrating the human brain with AI and
is the boring company which aims to bring
down the cost of tunnel boring by 10
fold.
Okay.
Elon Musk has been married two times.
He met his first wife, Justine Wilson,
while they were both students at
Queen's University in Ontario.
They tie the knots into thousands.
Justine is a fantasy novelist who
described her life with Elon as a dream
lifestyle. There was empty at the court.
Her husband was so focused on his work.
That's even when he was at home,
his mind,
it didn't seem to be that the marriage
ended in 2008 in a very messy public
divorce in on and Justine
have five children together,
a set of twins and a set of triplets.
Moscot met his second wife to do
the Riley has a London nightclub.
They were married just six weeks after
he filed for divorce from Justine.
The wedding took place.
It's Skeeto Carlson in Scotland.
He was 39 and she was 23 things apparently
didn't go well with MUSC announcing
their separation just two years later on
Twitter. It was an amazing four years.
I will love you forever. You will
make someone very happy. One day,
the couple they got back together in 2014
but the divorce was finalized towards
the end of 2016 when it comes
to the future of Elon Musk,
the best advice is to watch this space
has never backed down from his ambition
to travel to Mars, and it's
possibly even retire there one day.
Until that happens,
we can be assured that he will continue
to revolutionize the way that the world
consumes energy benefits from
technology and travels into space.
So I really hope you found that
video interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday. Also,
check out some of our previous videos
over that on the rise, and as always,
thank you for watching.